firefighters across europe are in a race
against time to protect people and their
homes
in france two fires around the town of
latest bouche in the southwest region of
gerond have been stabilized after having
destroyed thousands of hectares of land
we've managed to contain the fire we're
making it go where we want it to go
while protecting people and their
properties thankfully these two
objectives have been achieved
forest fire prevention teams have had to
cut down trees for a fire break
we are cutting down the trees so that if
the fire arrives there will be less
combustible mass which means a less
powerful fire and a support zone for
firemen to circulate better in spain
dozens of fires burn across the country
as temperatures push well into the
mid-40s
it's only making it more difficult to
extinguish the fire this area which is
green and cool in summer is becoming
very hot like the south climate change
affects everyone
the heat wave has caused hundreds of
deaths thousands of people forced to
evacuate their homes
we are doing very badly we are all very
stressed i live over there where the
terrace is i had to leave and come here
because i felt like the helicopters were
on top of me
some are seeking refuge in makeshift
shelters i didn't take it too seriously
i thought they had it under control and
i
was quite surprised whenever it started
seemed to be moving our direction and
then we were told to go so now we've
left a lot of stuff behind
others homes have burned the ground
i'm hurt my sister-in-law and my wife
have a farm that has burned the family
farm has burned all of it yes the whole
thing it is what it is
in greece a group of german firemen have
arrived to support emergency teams there
with hundreds more from across europe
expected to join the fight
much of the heat wave engulfing europe
comes from north africa where wildfires
like this one in morocco are also
wreaking havoc the extreme weather
episodes are expected to occur more
often as scientists point the finger to
climate change
chilean wolf al jazeera